- [Narrator] One of the distinct features
of this operation has been that
Israel has targeted a number
of high-rise buildings in Gaza.
The Israeli military is using
tanks and artillery fire,
unmanned drones, and other
sophisticated weapons.
The Palestinian militants
are firing mainly
unguided rockets into Israel.
(upbeat music)
(bomb exploding)
So there's been a quite of
wide path of destruction
on the civilian infrastructure
and civilian homes in Gaza.
(upbeat music)
Two specific towers that housed a number
of media organizations,
including one that housed both
the Associated Press and Al Jazeera,
the Israelis gave warning
to the owner of the building
to evacuate the building
and journalists from the AP,
and these other organizations
had to flee for their lives
before it was demolished.
The Israelis have said that there were
Hamas military intelligence,
using some offices in this building.
Both the AP and other
organizations have said
that they had no evidence
that that was the case.
(bomb exploding)
(upbeat music)
Gaza is territorially the
size of Washington DC,
but with the population about
three times the size of DC.
And so you can imagine the
difficulty of trying to
separate civilians from
anything you might be
trying to bomb in Gaza.
(upbeat music)
The Israeli military says that
what it's been targeting
is a system of tunnels
used by Palestinian
militants that is underneath
the neighborhoods of the Gaza strip,
as well as rocket construction facilities,
and militant leaders,
that it says are responsible
for these rocket attacks
from Gaza into Israel.
What we've found in our reporting is that
a lot of civilians have
died in these attacks.
(upbeat music)
Israel has said that they
were targeting a tunnel
and that the collapse of the building
was in accidental result of that attack.
It's a situation where
there are many people
the vast majority of them civilians
who are scared for their lives,
and they have nowhere to run
because they live in a territory
that's been cut off
from the outside world,
and it's a very dense urban center.
(upbeat music)
They're reaching further
into Israeli territory
attacking Tel Aviv and Jerusalem.
Israelis will tell you that
they are constantly hearing
sirens that force them to run
to their bomb shelters.
Palestinian militants, they
are using deadly weapons,
there's no doubt about that.
But they are at a disadvantage
when it comes to fighting Israel,
which is simply a much
more powerful military.
Israel has a missile defense
system called the Iron Dome,
which has intercepted they
say about 90% of rockets
that have reached Israeli territory.
(upbeat music)